these government officials want a closer
look at the rumbling volcano so they've
come to this military airbase in
Batangas province the plan to fly over
the crater of the tile volcano and this
site how to respond to the threat it
continues to pose it's been days since
tile erupted but the crisis is far from
over
we flew over lapaz city towards to a
lake what we saw there was beyond human
comprehension what was once a popular
tourist destination is now
unrecognizable from above we can see the
animals killed when all volcanoes spewed
steel and lava farmlands destroyed
communities damaged province in crisis
but in the middle of the destruction
some are daring to return for many this
is all that they have left
we finally reach the volcano's crater
this is what alert level four looks like
up close
experts are warning another eruption is
imminent seconds later a fountain of
black steam erupts and the pilot has to
maneuver quickly to escape a reminder of
how volatile the situation is what we
saw is based on my expectation also
based on the risk assessment on people
my heartbroken cataloger it was pretty
nasty the devastation was terrible as
far as the military is concerned we know
that a lot of things need to be done and
we encourage our citizens to calm down
and focus more than fifty thousand
people have been evacuated from a 40
kilometer danger zone
but beyond the physical discomfort
officials say it is the uncertainty of
what might happen next that praises the
government to prepare for the worst
volcanic eruptions are difficult to
accurately predict but more are expected
and government officials say they're
leaving nothing to chance
jemelle Alan doggin al-jazeera Batangas
province northern Philippines